I hear you got a permanent girlfriend
now permanent girlfriend you would you
were hitting it [ __ ] crazy out there
on the dating scene huh you finally
settled down yeah I mean this girl's so
awesome that I was like you know must be
super hot right super hot and you're not
[ __ ] anyone else not [ __ ] anybody
else Wow
yeah how long did it take her to lock
you down yeah like did you start dating
her and then you were exclusives are you
[ __ ] you know other people and now
you're settling down overlap transition
there was some overlap there yeah which
she's not too happy about see they think
like women so she's thinking oh he's
dating me so he's not [ __ ] anyone
else that'd be gross oh yeah yeah she's
gross that we had a UH
we had to talk last week she's very
grossed out by that right she's annoyed
by it but I'm like yeah you know we were
hanging out we were drinking a little
bit one night and then she goes hey I
gotta ask you something
uh you know you're on vacation a few
months ago and she's like I've looked at
your Instagram and I saw there was some
girl you were talking to and stuff and
she's like did you hook up no like yeah
right you were honest I was like at
least I'm honest about it yeah and I was
like you know we weren't exclusive
together I didn't know where she was at
and everything right and uh but women
generally think that like and now I get
it
now I'm a little older wiser like as
guys we really shouldn't like if you're
seeing someone and you are [ __ ] you
promised you'd only be [ __ ] them like
you like playing like a whole like
good-looking guys like you can get a lot
of girls but you shouldn't do that like
she only [ __ ] one person at a time I'm a
big believer in that there were times
where I'm hooking up with one girl I'm
like all this girl's awesome maybe I
should lock that down right and then
another opportunity comes up and I'm
like well if I miss that opportunity
right how do you know in the bank well
like like you know there was a girl that
I was seeing before her and then I'm
like well what if I was like exclusive
with that girl and I would never met her
you know no kidding I got to see a
picture of this girl like I'm coming way
too quick recently looking at her and
I'm like so into her that Wow it's
[ __ ] my game up you know I used to
get the hold out forever yeah in in
recent days
that's easy awesome hope you're doing
the job because they say that millennial
women are having a lot more sex but
fewer orgasms lucky they're not sleeping
with me so your girlfriend's ass is so
nice you come too quick too quick Wow
good for you the whole country you face
her whole body is so hot as [ __ ] and she
has a good personality great she's not
annoying bullets no yeah not a lot like
we've just been spending so much time
together like fun and you in love yeah
oh you're in love with her yeah when did
you fall in love about a month or two
ago no kidding yeah what do you love her
did you say it she said it first but I
was gonna say it that way yeah and then
we were drunk and she kind of slipped it
out and then she went ah [ __ ] like I
thought you were gonna say